it means no worries for the rest of your
days
[Music]
so in the club we just saw Simba
mentions the word problem-free if
something or someone is Problem free it
means that they don't have any problems
so the suffix free is used at the end of
many nouns to create adjectives meaning
without a particular thing some common
examples include fat free without fat
stress-free without stress or germ free
without germs but before we continue
learning with today's lesson every week
we publish new lessons like this one to
help English Learners like you
understand fast speaking natives without
getting lost without missing the jokes
and without needing subtitles so join
our Global community of over 6.5 million
Learners by hitting that subscribe
button and Bell down below so you never
miss out on any of our new lessons
when his father King Mufasa is killed
saving him from the wildebeest Stampede
young Simba feels guilty after his Sly
Uncle scar tricks him into believing it
was his fault
runs away from home and is soon taken in
by The Lovable Timon and Pumbaa repeat
after me
Hakuna Matata what Hakuna Matata it
means no worries
Hakuna Matata
what a wonderful phrase
Ain't No Passing craze in
all the rest of your days it's our
problem free
[Applause]
velocity
[Music]
yeah it's our motto what's the motto
nothing what's the motto with you
you know what these two words will solve
all your problems that's right take
Pumbaa for example why when he was a
young Ward hog when I was a
very nice thanks
he found his Aroma like a certain appeal
he could clear the Savannah after every
minute I must answer the soul though I
sing next skin
that my friends never stood down away
[Music]
not in front of the kids oh sorry
repeat after me
Hakuna Matata Hakuna Matata is a phrase
in the east African language of Swahili
that literally means no trouble or no
problems and is intended to encourage
people to make the most of the present
moment instead of worrying about the
future a similar phrase might be the
Latin expression Carpe Diem which means
to seize the day or live for the moment
what Hakuna Matata by the way did you
notice that Timon and Pumba pronounced
Matata differently Timon pronounces the
T sound with a flap T which means it
sounds similar to a D sound Hakuna
Matata this pronunciation is common in
American English on the other hand
Pumbaa pronounces the tea in Matata with
a true T sound meaning it is pronounced
with an air puff
Hakuna Matata
pumbas is closest to the actual Swahili
pronunciation
[Music]
something is a craze it is extremely
popular but a passing craze is something
that is very fashionable or trendy and
lots of people take part in it but it
passes quickly for example in the 90s
mood rings were a passing craze
Hakuna Matata it's our motto what's the
motto a motto is a short sentence or
phrase that expresses a rule or way of
Behaving especially in a particular
situation for example a popular motto
for having a positive attitude is when
life gives you lemons make lemonade
here's another nice example of this word
from Ice Age oh I remember when Manny
and I used to be like that not me love
them and leave them and take half of
everything that's my motto
yeah it's our motto what's the motto
nothing what's the motto with you
here we have a funny play on words
because when said fast motto sounds like
Mata what's the matter with you what's
the matter with you is also a cultural
reference to a line from the famous 90s
movie Goodfellas starring Robert De Niro
[Music]
what's the matter with you he found his
Aroma like a certain appeal if we say
that something lacks a certain appeal we
mean that there is something we do not
like about it if we do like something or
someone we can say that they or it is
appealing for example a positive
attitude is a very appealing
characteristic
he found his Aroma like a certain appeal
we use the word Aroma for a pleasant
smell or a good scent that you enjoy for
example a pot of coffee or a delicious
meal would have a good aroma however if
something smells bad if it stinks we
would say that it has an odor an aroma
smells but never stinks so Pumbaa
believes that his smell was pleasant but
that the other animals did not like it
how how did it go just perfect this time
you can describe their beautiful Aroma
to me
make it cleared us about I have to every
video the word clear has several
meanings which of these clips shows the
same meaning as in the scene
but if you would just listen not another
word and I am never never to hear of you
going to the surface again is that clear
we'll take one secret formula to go
clear the area citizens there's going to
be some serious aft kicking here I'd
like to introduce our panel Jonathan
Franzen Michael shabon and mo whoa Clear
Water swanky
[Music]
where are the area citizens there's
going to be some serious aft kicking
here
the answer is B to clear an area as
Pumbaa and SpongeBob did means to empty
a space or make everyone leave a
particular place
in The Little Mermaid when King Triton
asks if that is clear he means do you
understand
in The Simpsons when Mo refers to Clear
Water he means water that is pure or
easy to see through
the
[Music]
noun a sensitive soul is what we would
call a person who is easily hurt
emotionally check out this example hey
why won't you head upstairs I'll be
right up okay oh thank you
you know you try to hide it but you are
a sensitive Soul we use the adjective
sensitive to describe someone who is
easily upset or emotional here's a nice
example from Friends
do you realize that man has cried in our
apartment three times huh I haven't
cried that many times since I moved in
sensitive that's all isn't it fun to
learn vocabulary in context like this
this is key to becoming a fluent
confident English speaker he has learned
English with TV series friends is
without a doubt our favorite TV series
because actually it's the best one to
learn English with in fact there's even
academic studies that prove this so
knowing this inspired us to create our
fluent with friends course to help you
have fun and greatly improve your
understanding of fast-speaking natives
learn the vocabulary you actually need
to communicate confidently and massive
grammar in context also you can finally
speak English naturally like you've
always wanted to and you can try it
right now for free with our three-part
masterclass simply sign up right now by
clicking up here or down in the
description below
in my sensitive Soul now I sing that
skin
we just learned what it means to be a
sensitive soul but how about to be
thick-skinned
if you say that someone is thick-skinned
you mean that they are not easily upset
by criticism or insults in a way you
could say it's the opposite of being a
sensitive Soul an example would be you
need to be thick-skinned to survive as a
politician and it hurt that my friends
never stood down
the wind blows from upwind to downwind
if you are downwind of a chemical plant
or a smelly person or animal the wind
blows that smell to you so none of the
other animals were willing to stand
where they could smell Pumbaa in the
following examples scar teaches Simba
that when a lion goes hunting they would
stay downwind from their prey so that
they could smell the prey but the prey
can't smell them if you wish to kill
something you might want to stay
downwind
I know how to hunt Uncle scar
Ed
if someone is ashamed they feel
distressed or embarrassed by feelings of
guilt foolishness or disgrace
for example he felt incredibly ashamed
after getting angry during the meeting
absolutely
it's all thanks to you kid you made it
possible Jack I said no claiming
[Music]
let's look at the pronunciation here
notes that of is reduced to a schwa
sound so the entire word sounds like uh
together it sounds like thought of
changing my name I'm Gonna Change
[Music]
if you are down-hearted you are feeling
sad and discouraged for example the boy
was down-hearted after he failed the
exam
ah gosh she seems so I don't know sit
down-hearted Big Mama well you can't
blame him honey
he was dropped out here and left all
alone without a friend in the world
soon Simba starts to accept the Hakuna
Matata motto and Embraces his life with
his two new friends let's take a look
wherever we want
I'm telling you kid this is the great
life no rules no responsibilities
slimy yet
satisfying that's it we didn't lie
when someone welcomes you to their
Humble Home it means that they feel that
their house is ordinary and not very
special it is often meant to be humorous
so when someone says welcome to my
humble home they are saying don't judge
me by my surroundings my Hospitality
will make up for it live here well we
live wherever we want do as we please
when Pumbaa uses the expression we do as
we please he means that he and Timon eat
and do whatever they want whenever they
want an example would be when she asked
the parents if she could go out they
responded go or don't go do as you
please that my friend is a lion what
about food have you thought about
beating that thing yeah I'm starved I
can eat a whole zebra which of these is
the opposite of starved
Hungry full
stuffed
full and stuffed can both be used after
you eat more than enough or if you eat
too much however stuffed is used in more
informal situations I could eat a whole
zebra is a play on the common expression
I could eat a whole horse which means
that you are so hungry you could eat
more than you usually do
[Music]
hungry I could literally eat a horse
right now
uh no no kid uh we're fresh on a zebra
any Antelope to be fresh out of means
that you have just
sold all
thing
sorry gents we're fresh out I only make
one batch a day when they're gone I'm
done in the Antelope uh oh yes Simba
asks the question do you have any
Antelope but as you can see he emits the
auxiliary verbs do and have as well as
the subject you it is very common for
native speakers to omit the auxiliary in
questions especially in casual
conversations
the key is to pay close attention to the
intonation used as questions usually end
in Rising intonation let's take a look
at some examples where'd you get that in
my mom's closet you like it not too
retro Rachel any messages
no listen kid if you want to live with
us you have to eat like us let's look at
the connected speech here first Timon
reduces you to ya then the o sound in
two is pronounced with the schwa so it
sounds like ta we can hear that have and
to flow into each other so together it
becomes you have to eat like us you have
to eat like us I'm telling you kid this
is the great life no rules no
responsibilities to live with no rules
and no responsibilities means to live
life the way you choose and to not
follow anyone else's rules and laws if
you do not have any responsibilities you
don't need to do things such as paying
bills attending school or having a job
slimy yep
that's fine when something is slimy it
feels thick wet and unpleasant when
something is satisfying it gives you
fulfillment or the pleasure associated
with it so when Simba swallows the bug
and says slimy yet satisfying he means
that at first it feels unpleasant but
then it leaves him feeling Pleasant
that's it we demise exactly
back
repeat after me
Hakuna Matata what Hakuna Matata it
means no worries Hakuna Matata
what a wonderful phrase
Hakuna Matata Ain't No Passing craze
a passing craze is
unpopular
popular and lasts a long time popular
but doesn't last a long time
[Music]
it means no worries for the rest of your
days
[Applause]
[Music]
Hakuna Matata yeah it's our motto what's
the motto nothing what's the motto with
you
you know what these two words will solve
all your problems that's right take
Pumbaa for example why when he was a
young Ward hog when I was a young word
very nice thanks
he found his Aroma like a certain appeal
he could clear to Savannah after every
meal what is the opposite of aroma
taste Oda
sight
[Music]
Los Angeles
and it hurt that my friends never stood
down away
[Music]
not in front of the kids oh sorry yeah
I'm starved I can eat a whole zebra oh
here we go uh no no kid uh we're fresh
on a zebra what does being fresh out of
mean
you have recently run out of something
you have some products left you want to
get some fresh air
[Music]
slimy yep
satisfying that's it we didn't lie
so I hope you enjoyed today's lesson and
that you learned something new if you
would like to continue learning with
Disney then be sure to check out this
lesson next
is that my Pocahontas
grandmother willow I need to talk to you
I was hoping you'd visit today oh wow
your mother's necklace that's what I
wanted to talk to you about
my father wants me to marry kokum cool
cool but he's so serious I know my
father thinks it's the right path for me
but lately I've been having this dream
and I think it's oh a dream